let's get out to desert inn and decatur
near cashman middle school that's where
sasha loftis is live tonight sasha
denise and brian a very active scene
here on desert inn at decatur as police
investigate this deadly crash involving
a school bus and a pedestrian you can
see there are several school buses on
the scene here no word on which school
bus was involved but authorities say a
school bus hit that pedestrian that
person died here on the scene we are
still working to gather details as to
what led up to this crash but of course
you'll want to watch for road closures
you can see desert inn is shut down in
each direction
east of decatur again desert inn and
decatur a deadly crash involving a
school bus and a pedestrian no word on
whether children were on board we did
see a few walking around here with their
parents we will of course bring you the
latest updates as we work on getting
more details confirmed here but again
for now avoid this area this deadly
crash here on desert inn near decatur
this should stay closed for the next
couple of hours reporting live sasha
loftis live local now